a fence in Hungary border controls in
Austria thousands of refugees stranded
at the Greek border to Macedonia the
closing of the infamous Balkan route for
EU leaders at today's summit the most
contentious issue but a frog weakened we
are talking about bringing down the
numbers of refugees for example in
Greece we are not talking about closing
anything the Greenland can a snitch
tujunga in the cylinder at was gosh
watsonville it's a matter of definition
other leaders insist is keep Kenny route
there's no open route anymore we are in
favor of organized relocation officially
closed or not overwhelmed by refugees
Greece is facing a humanitarian crisis
to provide relief EU leaders last
september's agreed to relocate 160
thousand refugees today fewer than 700
have been sent to other countries there
were agreements that didn't implement it
implement for everybody this is a
problem for our common home for Europe
if there are agreements that we not
implement there are not agreements at
all and then there's Turkey Turkish
Prime Minister Ahmet Davutoglu guest of
honor at today's summit EU leaders want
him to control Turkey sporters fight
human trafficking and take back illegal
migrants but he made clear at his
arrival all that will come at a price
turkey is ready to work with you turkey
is ready to be member of EU as well
according to a plan by the EU Commission
Greece has now until May to secure the e
use external borders with support of
NATO frontex and Turkey if that fails
member states can officially suspend the
Schengen rules and keep their borders
closed